all right look alive team and our she
blows
can anyone point out the mistakes the
three made in the semi later the
engineer puked in the main gearbox sorry
we shouldn't be doing this you know for
someone in a space exploration program
you don't have much of a sense of
adventure I've been scanning the system
and picking up alien radio chatter they
keep repeating one word Voltron it is
time to reclaim what is rightfully ours
yes soon you'll rule the universe guys
you should come see this what is that
whoa good kitty
you're the worst where are we
u5 were brought here for a reason
together you will form Voltron the
greatest weapon ever known protector of
the innocent
and our only hope to save the universe
jeez no pressure
defenders of the universe are it's got a
nice ring to it
DreamWorks Voltron legendary defender
all episodes June 10th only on Netflix
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my Voltron video if you have
absolutely no idea what's going on
Voltron is back via Netflix most of you
have probably heard that Netflix is
doing a Legend of Zelda series what
they're calling it is a reboot of the 84
series it's being made by the same
people that made Legend of Korra and the
same animation studio Studio Mir which
is ironic because Steven Yeun who played
avatar wandering Legend of Korra is
playing Keith so if you're really sad
that Korra went away because not only
was it a really amazing series with
amazing mythology it was also one of the
most beautifully animated series from
the last 10 years which explains part of
the reason why it went away because it
was so hard to animate because they made
it look so good but because it's Netflix
all the episodes are dropping on June
10th the first episode is a full
hour-long than the other twelve episodes
are all 22 minutes so it's a half hour
series but the premiere is intended to
be like a really long ova type episode
but depending on how old you are you may
have seen some of the other versions of
Voltron the 1984 series was my entry
point I was a little too young to catch
it on its first run but I ended up
seeing it during reruns there were a
couple series after that like fleet of
doom
third dimension just to give you a
really quick history on the series when
it first started lion forced Voltron was
an adaptation of a Japanese anime series
called beast king go lion the people in
the United States that aired it took a
lot of the pieces of the Japanese series
and they just added new bits to it they
had trouble translating a lot of the
Japanese storylines so they cut like
completely new scenes and just added it
to the robot parts and then cut out some
of the rolling violence stuff because it
was intended to be viewed by really
small children so they took a lot of the
bones from the Japanese anime series and
then just added a bunch of Americanized
stuff to it they kind of did the same
thing with Power Rangers if you ever saw
Power Rangers a lot of the kaiju scenes
when they're fighting in their outfits
and you can't see their mouths move
that's copy pasted from a Japanese anime
series and then when they're filming the
actors walking around talking to each
other without their costumes on
that's film new so new company comes
along takes bits from the old series
adds new stuff and then packages it is a
new television series
that's how lion forged Voltron got
started vehicle force Voltron which came
at the tail end of lion force Voltron
was adapted from armored fleet de
rigueur so two completely different
Japanese mecha anime Sierra
repurposed and packaged as lion forest
Voltron and Miko force Voltron after all
those episodes aired
they had like a big team up movie called
Fleet of Doom where lion forest and
vehicle force Voltron teamed up to fight
King Zarkon so originally that all
dropped during the mid-1980s but but
obviously it aired a lot during reruns
so that's where I saw it that's where
probably a lot of you saw it then like
12 years after that in the late 90s they
tried to do another reboot called
Voltron third dimension when people talk
about the terrible Voltron reboot that's
what they're talking about you may
completely ignore third dimension just
pretend like it never existed the same
goes for Voltron Force which was another
attempted reboot around 2010-2011 just
pretend like that never existed either
instead of being a reboot that was
actually intended to be a sequel to the
1984 series so instead of meeting
everybody for the first time again it's
like the Drule have returned King lotor
is now in charge the Voltron Force comes
out of semi-retirement to fight them
again so you have the classic 1984
series the big team up movie then you
have a couple attempted reboots which we
could just pretend like it hasn't
existed and now we have the legend of
core people who have come along and said
here's a version of Voltron that is not
going to totally suck so I'm so excited
and I'm so happy that the Korra team was
able to stay together the best thing you
can do to get ready is to watch episodes
of Legend of Korra which I think are
streaming on Nickelodeon's website and
to watch the original Voltron series
which is streaming on Hulu so you get
about a month to get ready when it does
drop I'll try to do videos like I did
for Jessica Jones or daredevil like the
other Netflix series that I've done
videos for I probably won't do videos
for every single episode but I'll try to
do some kind of giveaway so be sure to
subscribe to get everything I'll try to
think of something fun to give away I
don't know if Peter Cullen who most of
you probably just recognize as Optimus
Prime from transformers is going to do
the narration like he narrated the
original Voltron series but all the
characters are going to be the
characters of the 1984 series I think
some of the situations that they're
involved in will be a little bit
different but this is not intended to be
the sequel so when they discovered lion
force Voltron they'll be discovering it
for the first time so really excited
everybody be sure to watch some Voltron
and some Legend of Korra before this
gets here there are a couple other
really big comic book things that I'm
still catching up on so while you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here for my Avengers infinity war
tease
and you can click here for all my
legends of four videos but everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
protector of the innocent and our only
hope to save the universe